good more
we listen to the podcast back they all
start
with us like saying morning Millennials
so I just wanted to start it a little
differently so that we can differentiate
this episode why is this episode like
any other so no why is this night
different from all other nights why is
this happened if ur inform all other
because we're finally back and we're
finally ten I just like honestly and
it's finally spring it's finally spring
has sprung but more importantly that's
my tan I feel like I've never been on
first of all we like a cousin I've never
been Sun is so strong there so I think
it's the strongest Sun I've ever
experienced a hundred percent like sense
doesn't work oh do them work I might as
well close be usually worse if I wear a
layer of sub-tree I never have to
reapply and I don't get sunburned
so not only were we in like the hottest
whisper with the strongest Sun of her we
were also there for the longest time
ever so like I don't think I've ever had
this thin dark of a tan like I look
amazing like I know I look amazing
yeah and I know you agree I did so this
morning I was doing makeup I was like oh
no none of my foundations are gonna work
like nothing's gonna work and it's very
clear that I've been buying all the
wrong products my life because all the
products and now we're made for my skin
tone so I don't know whatever I don't
know what I'm gonna do when I go back to
you should maintain this tan like
through the spring/summer okay and I
think to do it through a constant stream
of spray tan I can't spray tan and
gently get a spray tan I regret it and
sitting like on a rooftop this is my
cycle of thought when I get a spray tan
and planning trips like yeah every two
weeks you should be going somewhere warm
hitting the Sun okay this is my problem
spray tans get to a point where I'm
literally the Michelin Man I'm white and
puffy and Rolly I'm like you know what
would make look less puffy and really
it's if I was like a little darker so I
get a spray tan just like I have a whole
day leading up to the spray tan because
it's like oh I can't sweat actually make
a bob what if I do brah they're like its
whole thing finally get there am I so
relieved and I'm always like you know
what what shape should I do and then I'm
like you know just give me what I did
last time and I'm always wishing I went
one lighter look and then I smell and
all my sheets like are shit-stained and
it's like a problem I understand but I
do think that the benefits well there's
only really one benefit which is you
look a little prettier in a little
thinner a lot which outweigh the
which is the smelliness the Treach of
showering but this place that I go to
doesn't express so I only have to wait
two hours like the wind shower is not my
problem like it's literally STUV my
problem what's the most everything all
the stretch and I don't even like the
way that it looks
you know it's crazy I was thinking about
though your sound system with my sound
okay let's just take a moment
move your mic up better testing sorry
guys I think what's crazy Matt's pretty
tense it's like they used to be shamed
for so long it was like you know you
don't go into bed and now it's like now
although all those people died
now all the normal people who know that
sweet heading is better are still up
it's like I feel like Kim Kardashian did
a lot for him because it's like she's
the tannest like oh wait oh constantly
tan
Jimmy Coco what's that Jimmy Coco what's
that it's like the spray tanner oh is it
he does like she chooses to spray tan
you and not use a bed but everyone mean
college I got a spray tan my friends
were going to them I went into a bed
once what yeah I got peer pressured into
it it's horrible the scariest moment of
my life is my sound okay but why is that
is it is it a physical or a technical
physical manifestation of my sound move
it up more it just I'm high up how am i
I'm gonna and what about me better it's
the live stream okay you know what
welcome to the podcast what were we
saying um the physical oh no sorry we
were saying you went to a bed oh my god
okay I got peer pressured into it in the
head and like I just like everyone
around me is so tan and I just like want
to leg up on the competition
so I and it was treacherous and I was so
afraid and I think I did it wrong
because there's a special area for your
head I'm face but I just put like my
whole thing the thing that was calling
me right now no one who doesn't I tell
marketer hate one of my best friends I'm
live maybe he thinks you're some
vacation
dude he wants to be in on the show yeah
maybe is something breaking news he's
like private so like he would said if I
did that I think okay but he's the one
calling you you think it's 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time
there's no way it's breaking news and so
we're getting so off track I can't go in
a bed I would feel like some like oh
here that's just one of the fears
because it's a [ __ ] coffin literally
I will never know like a horse has never
been in a bed like values her life
totally I'm letting you know so the cast
is not gonna be around for much time
they bed did you ever watch it so does
it work
I don't know chill all I think of that
tanning that was spray tanning and sun
tanning oh my god I can't with beds that
gives me such anxiety yeah
claustrophobia totally miss keeping in
we're in a coffin anyways never gotten
an MRI no have you got no Ben has twice
and that's a true coffee snob sad so
that's so scary because like you those
are good for you unlike tanning beds
right like it's a Gerta combat what
Thanks yeah dude stop so yeah but we're
not talking about that what I think I
heard myself saying stop stop like I was
being Sam oh well I feel like my sound
isn't working but whatever we have such
a busy show for you today we have
obviously the Fast Five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast oh wow
that was close you can also smell your
morning toast guys yes so Malan before
you take a bite all your ingredients are
fresh and not expire don't be afraid and
then it's Wednesday so we have lots of
dear toasters from honestly some of some
of our more [ __ ] up listeners like
they're crazy yeah well we don't know
what the dear toasters are we've just
been told that they're crazy
oh but today is amaz your special day
because it's also the first day of our
brand-new intern Jacob who's right over
here in the corner he's so cute and
that's Apollo minister and he's gonna
help make the shows more premium yeah
like every way it's a win for everyone
yeah I mean it is his first day in my
audio is not working so like he might
get fired but birthday yes oh my god
hold on I have to text him immediately
you guys really get such a sec what's up
run such a fun time on the podcast
yesterday that episode was so federal
money to film and it's so funny because
our audio was amazing like probably like
better than it is right now we were in
the loudest lounge but that little
thing that we got is amazing you
couldn't hear anything so we're like so
self-conscious and laughing and it made
the episode so funny and then the people
with the dominoes people it was just a
perfect
I tried celerity happy birthday bro bro
bro bro okay so sorry as we were saying
we have dear toasters we have the Fast
Five and then we have a very special
guest kind of controversial yeah well
I'm so so it seems so it seems we member
every newest cast member of southern
charm Bravo southern charm is here we
met her she couldn't have been more
lovely beautiful and Thomas is here
Thomas is here so like not only two
cheeks heed my expectations just by
being a lovely person like she wrote on
it so like I'm dead and I'm forever in
that and Thomas is like like a gentleman
like we asked if he wants to come on
he's like you don't let her you know
yeah I'm so excited to talk to that
Thomas understands like how big of a
platform this is and he wouldn't want to
in turn look at the platform no I'm so
excited to get to know them like we've
never seen them before because I feel
like we're capable of bringing that out
in people and maybe what we see on
southern charm is in all these no there
is this is what the toast is all about
just you know giving people shedding
light shedding light and we don't let
people's pastic take their futures
exactly what a beautiful note to begin
on let's jump in to our first story the
chick is gonna read from her beloved
iPad beloved oh my god
speaking of snap Jersey Shore star
Ronnie ortiz-magro apologizes after
putting baby mama on blast and explosive
Instagram fights out of control this was
messy as [ __ ] and I honestly don't even
want to go into the sordid details
because like we're too good for this no
and it's like you're are way too old to
be fighting on social media you have a
child like yeah take a note out of Kim's
book and stop saying bad things they're
out of and then like in the middle of
all this he's hanging out with Sheena
how do you get from your well I get I
get it they both live in Vegas but
anytime I see Ronnie's name in the
headlines it really pisses me off
because it's like you spelled margo
wrong but I was like oh this is my
office
oh so we need to clarify Ronnie does not
live in Vegas he lives in Nevada
oh he lives in the suburbs of the Sin
City like I know that block take this is
bigger than the strip but it's like
really not and he lives in I think it's
um Reno yes okay so here are some of the
details Jersey Shore star Ronnie our
keys man
girl has apologized after getting into a
nasty fight with his girlfriend and baby
mama mama gen Harley airing their dirty
laundry out on social media Ronni social
media battle began when he posted an
Instagram
note to self can't turn a natural-born
ho into a housewife if it finally got
her and then leave them in the gutter he
continued not all people can be saved
when they are so far gone all you can
say you did your best and keep it moving
he captioned the photo with the hashtag
fax fax and yeah buddy he followed that
up with another IG shortly after one
which gave a little more insight into
the feud if your significant other keeps
sex videos of their ex shouldn't they
show enough respect to delete them
especially after being in a new
relationship for over a year he asked
along with a yes-no poll for fans to
audience interaction but Ronnie wasn't
done yet he then shared two text message
conversations one which appears to be
with his Jersey Shore co-stars in a
group called Justice we famous fam used
to be of his girlfriend's alleged racy
video someone named Dina likely Deena
Cortese asked what girl even keeps that
lol Ron's response exactly another text
message to someone named Mikey possibly
the situation had the caption so
everyone knows I'm not a cheating
scumbag my actions are cause our cause
my disgrace and fidelity in addition to
those post he also shared messages from
fans who had his back we also on the
other side his Big Momma accused him of
doing drugs yes you cheater
not even a cutie like she had the bag of
cocaine like that was right it was empty
here's the thing everyone knows how I
feel about Ronnie like he's truly like
manipulative and abusive and like
watching real house I'm watching Jersey
Shore back as an adult it's quite
eye-opening to like to see like whatever
you we had a front-row seat to an
abusive relationship like and here it is
again like I don't know what's coming on
I don't know what she didn't like he's
out of control seriously and if I ever
end at end like I would genuinely be
afraid of him partly because I've spoken
so much [ __ ] about him on the show but
like he has got to stop yeah maybe wait
what has he got to do stop maybe someone
needs to tell him like Ron maybe you
were the problem like it's not everyone
else it's you but I also feel like his
his castmates should be holding him
accountable and I feel like they've
tried to get they should be holding him
it could have gone it was ya know but
you know have I ever let anything go no
but they should be holding him account
because he needs to be a better man he's
a father now Mike well I just saw you
scroll to the second story and like I'm
so excited about it because it has like
it's just it's a tangled web of lies a
tangled web of lies okay but have
anything else to say by Ronnie uh no but
I haven't caught up on Jersey Shore
family vacation speaks to the show not
to me and the situation is engaged I
just wanted to say I know oh my god I'm
so he's over here that girl is
ride-or-die that she was with him and
like she started dating him at his
lowest like not even when he was famous
and she's just been like riding this
wave and like good for them I think
she's the real deal I think they're the
real deal and the worlds of Florida
Georgia line it's meant to be if it's
meant to be it will be baby just let it
be baby I love that song
it's literally the best song it's Jackie
disagrees I don't think it's the best
song it's a good song for the radio but
I think when it doesn't move me when
bebe Rexha comes on it's unbelievable
and I think part of the reason why I
like it so much is because I've been
watching the season of American Idol and
this guy Caleb who you would love he
like lost 70 pounds in the year that he
has been on American Idol I'm like a
little bit before that I mean that's
amazing I feel like so many people in
between auditions and Holly yeah like
lost weight and he's like he's just like
having this like moment where like he's
like growing up he lost a lot of weight
he's that kind of handsome man like the
judges are just like loving watching him
like grow up and he's the most amazing
like southern country boys he doesn't
have to try when he sings and he picks
the best songs and when they did
pairings they paired celebrities singers
with the artists he sang meant to be
with Bieber ex and he's saying the
Florida Georgia line song and it was so
good that's good okay I'll listen to
that but I think I just led the song as
a song it's like very simple and basic
and it just it doesn't do much for me
but it doesn't do nothing like it
doesn't take away no you understand like
we're going to CMA fest and I just wanna
let you know like when Florida Georgia
line comes on and they undoubtedly sing
that song with her that bebe Rexha like
you will not be able to find me cuz I'll
be dead in the ground six feet under
that's beautiful I'm so excited for some
so say I was oh by the way cuz it was
also stated so just weekend and we
happen to a planned our trip right
during stagecoach so we weren't able to
go and like I was having MS your phone
especially because Kacey Musgraves was
there like she doesn't perform anyway
you know what's weird is I was having
major from I was watching everything
that I could find on Instagram Instagram
stories and everyone was posting
everything except no one posted Kacey
Musgraves which is weird I feel like
people like don't love her as much as we
do no she is
Klee a country artist but like really
sone categorizes her as like alternative
and she started in country and she'll I
grew up in a trailer park some people
like things she's country but like she's
really like indie but she's country but
she's but her latest album is not
country but it's okay it's good I don't
know see my apartment loved it like the
way that we do like I don't know I would
have been like dying for her no no you
don't understand I would have in my
whole story he's not at CMA fest like
just please coming out I can't and also
to be at CMA fest let me think let me
think let me think
one word protection Mason Ramsay yeah we
that's part of the reason we're being
flown out to CMA fest is were part of
his security detail just we need to
protect him at all costs I'm head of
Mason Ramsey's emotional emotional
security yep and I think I'm doing a
really good job because he seems great
and like whatever it takes I was half at
nothing to protect him let's go to move
into our second story speaking of
someone who was not protected no that's
exactly what it is
Avicii suicide was by broken glasses TMZ
so here's the story and according to
teams according to TMZ who has lied
before and told us at Haley steel I was
definitely dating Justin Bieber when
Jimmy definitely not TMZ lied straight
to my face on television okay
they literally made up lies about me
multiple they say it Donald Trump
tweeted at me like and they also said I
had 8.2 million followers which thank
you but I've 2.8 so like I can barely
take anything they say at face value
anymore where I used to come to him as
like my number one source of information
totally I thought utilize I know it I
wanted rebuttal and also you know what
else they did they had that video of
Tristan since October and they didn't
post it and drill all the [ __ ] came out
so like I used to trust them implicitly
and after a series of a series of
unfortunate events I no longer trust
them and here is another event which is
extremely unfortunate
avicii committed suicide with broken
glass he used to cut himself TMZ has
learned multiple sources familiar with
the circumstances surrounding his famous
DJ's death tell us he and did take his
own life something as parents alluded to
last week our sources say the method of
death was a shard glass that caused
massive bleeding two sources tell us of
each you broke a bottle and use the
glass to inflict the fatal wound one of
the sources says it was a wine bottle
two sources tell us the point of injury
was avicii's neck but another strongly
denies right
saying it was his wrist we cannot
confirm this but the sources were privy
to specific information about avicii's
death as TMZ reported the 28 year old
was found dead April 20th in the middle
in the Middle Eastern country of Oman he
battled alcohol problems for years and
his friends worried those issues would
eventually kill please wait I just want
to say something I know what you're
gonna say
and they know what you're gonna say I
just want to say if what you're saying
is true be careful about what you say
I'm so true because he's Avicii I could
be next and you could be next is all I'm
saying
after all according to TMZ 8.2 million
dollars right this is what I'll say his
family did release a message that
included that it was suicide saying he's
really struggle with thoughts about
meaning like happiness he could not go
anywhere he wanted sometimes a list you
don't go to like a red I'm country the
Middle East to like I mean I don't know
I've never like killed myself but you
just you don't do that I feel like you
know I mean yeah here's the thing
everyone knows what's really going on he
didn't really kill himself like this is
another mark sailing at its finest and
TMZ also perpetuated that mark they
never even questioned whether or not
like this dude you know that like mark
sailing had defensive wounds under his
fingernails like no because he fought
for his life but you think he committed
suicide but no he is really about to
give up the names of some of the biggest
pedophiles in Hollywood and died the
next day
so now a beach he's in a club a cup a
week before he died in a club where he
saw literally like a 90 year old man and
a 12 year old girl like interacting in a
way that was not consensual and he tried
to protect the girl this is what the
blinds say he tried to protect the girl
and we didn't know that they were
married so this guy like was really
upset and then a B G like fell down a
rabbit hole of like human trafficking
and like all these things in Hollywood
and he was planning on doing a
documentary and now there is no
documentary in there there's no Avicii
so if you want to believe what TMZ tells
you and just be blind to the atrocities
of our world then please by all means
it's ignorance truly is blessed truly
but because of my addiction to blind
gossip I I'm not I can't be as fortunate
I don't have any intern and also the
addiction to this story just not adding
up
does not add up so it just it makes you
turn to buying awesome because some of
the family whose brother flew out like
right before to that Middle Eastern
country to like see him I don't know
it's just all so weird it's so weird I'm
not telling
anything about it because I didn't even
read those lines and honestly I don't
want trouble but no if the troublemakers
are listening please know this I don't
know any of your names so I won't say
them so please don't come after me thank
you thank you
speaking of trouble
Tristan Thompson breaks social media
silence after Khloe Kardashian cheating
scandal okay I forgot that Beach I'm at
this but anyways he posted to his
Instagram what an atmosphere in the
queue great win hashtag on to the next
one says every time he has the ball the
chant Khloe that's [ __ ] hilarious and
he's playing amazingly which apparently
is him no no but every time third
trimester Thompson every time he cheats
oh no but playing amazingly yeah it's
like unclear if he's a good player or
not I haven't got a straight answer from
these that's why he's being good right
now you said on the show know what I'm
gonna do I'm just gonna actually I feel
like he doesn't know basketball can't
see yeah I was Nick he's Tristan
Thompson guy Jacob do you know
basketball does anyone do you know best
me yeah that's what last time we asked
the room we gotta this yeah everyone's
like you know sometimes good sometimes
bad I mean he's no he's no Kobe Jackie
if Kobe literally came up to you like
Saturday face yes yes he's no LeBron and
I would know him because of course of
course
I love LeBron yeah you're like the only
one I love his personality
yes like I feel like I'm the only one
who loves him for his personality and
not his basketball skills and if he
really who does for how for how long and
I thought it was 18 million you know
it's just like five years each in a two
million dollar contract
not too shabby I'll see ya must be nice
must be nice anyway should do with 82
million dollars retire to Texan of
course but like I don't I would retire
Turks and he goes no seriously if I had
eighty million dollars I would put away
fifty two million of it no no sixty-two
million of it just earned interest like
make money you know invest and then the
22 million I would just like live off up
for the rest of my life like in a nice
house I wouldn't buy a private jet cause
it's like expensive to maintain but I
wouldn't and if you're retired like
where you going traveling seeing the
world I thought you said that doesn't
interest it doesn't but like maybe if I
was rich it would yeah maybe it the
right way
Allen doesn't interest me because I was
like City coach and likes a hostage yeah
but like if I had a private plane and
like I don't know I could say the Ritz
put it on there it's yeah okay there um
anyways I had a dream about Chloe and
Tristan last night wow it's just hitting
me that's what they were like trying to
make it work and he was like still being
rude to her and she like threw came out
of her room for trying to tell her the
truth
I'm like were you there you were just
watching on TV I was there how
interesting was weird I was like out of
preview for I don't even know I think it
was like I don't know my dreams in
reality I was just complaining and it
and it's just so crazy I don't know what
you wanna know why because we live in
the dream you know okay this forest
story I know you're gonna have a lot of
thoughts on okay I know it Busy Philipps
is getting a talk show he has ordered
busy tonight the working title a talk
show hosted an executive produced by
cougar town actress our sister site
deadline reports and I guess it's
because her delightful Instagram stories
are getting the TV treatment is what TV
line is saying oh okay so Instagram
stories is now like an auditioning
platform for TV then like I would have
had one a year ago um this is just what
I want to say like she's fine there's
nothing wrong with her but like her
husband's a successful producer like I'm
just like so over people getting things
like because of like who they're related
to you know what I mean yeah it's like
enough already
like Krejci is funny Instagram story
it's like so don't half the people on
the internet then you meet them in real
life and they're like morons yeah it's
like people from the internet like it's
so sad like okay so traditional media
like randomly plucks people from the
internet and giving the opportunity and
then like it's always a failure
Anthony Mota yeah it's always a failure
and then like internet people get like
this bad stigma because they gave grace
he'll make a show like pick better
people from the internet who would you
pay who do you think is Internet that's
real oh wow
tough question I say oh do you know girl
with no job and Jackie oh yes I would
choose them Wow like those girls can
talk for over an hour straight yeah and
if they've just talked a little bit
slower it'd be two hours so I'm just
saying like talking directly into your
phone and being like quirky
isn't the talent anymore I agree we're
so beyond elevated like we're better
than that and I'm just like I don't know
I'm over it like great like and then
it's just busy Phillips obviously
be a failure like and then they're gonna
be like so temptation it's about giving
another show to another digital
personality because Busy Philipps failed
it s all about Phillips a digital person
now she is really I don't follow her
stuff but you know what I did she did
like she does like brand partnerships
she like worked with betches like she's
digital now oh wow that's crazy I am is
obsessed with her Instagram stories and
puts all of her k'kaw fragrance stuff on
the Instagram stories yeah she's an
influencer world are we living in she's
an influencer who happened to be in
white chicks and Dawson's Creek and I
started watching freaks and geeks on the
plane and she's in it yeah by the way
I've been begging you to watch radiates
did you like watching I watched four
episodes I liked it like I got it I was
laughing at Linda Cardellini dad you go
to the prom and then you guys wait it's
so weird that it's Linda Cardellini cool
in the cart I thought it was Chucky I'm
about to blow your mind no no that's
what I knew about chutney from you know
yes yes when I use Asian I know I mean
II was in free singing you're like hey
Lindsay like this cute little girl and
then like literally she never worked
again and nobody realized that she was
the iconic role of Chucky in Italy blah
she's held Brooke Windham husband she
didn't mean to shoot him that he's Linda
Cardellini you guys and she's working
again she's and dad hey Tito that's well
I knew she was in daddy's home and
honestly when I saw her in freak sneaks
I couldn't get the timelines right I was
like oh it's Zoey doing yeah until the
credits rolled in it was Linda
Cardellini I was like I don't know
exactly the moment I realized Linda
Cardellini was also chummy like my life
was never the same
that's shocking oh my god I can't watch
anymore so we have one more song dear
toasters is that the line and everyone's
in love with Linda Cardellini yeah but
um I just want to say I'd like a note
because they are like the pie not the
panel apple pineapple Express oh gee
crew you know that crew yeah Judd Apatow
and Jason Segel so the bee's knees
he is the hottest man like I've always
thought he was so key but he's like at
his prime in freak singing yeah and also
like in Forgetting Sarah Marshall oh
yeah when people like when people try
and actually my type is the kind of
change because like I just say John
Mayer's my type
like he has and he looks like then so I
feel like it's not cheating but like
like Jason Segel Vince Vaughn John
Mayer's like so my tight like chubby but
like slim not slim no but like not like
obese yeah like one of those okay Ben is
on keto he's like getting so skinny it's
like make me so fast oh my god today is
day one of my whole new lifestyle I took
so many vitamins this morning I'm just
I'm trying to just change my way of life
and today's what I'm doing what I've
been doing is not working and today's
day one of just being happy for me so
yeah it's too soon to tell how this
one's gonna go but maybe my vitamins
will make me feel better because it's
like when I'm I don't get enough iron
but now I'm taking iron so maybe I'll be
okay maybe this final story is truly a
blessing true Hollywood story is
returning to e so good story no but it's
okay well first of all the headline is
true Hollywood story is what it's called
I always thought it was know things but
it's E's story so they're not gonna say
e yeah but like anyways a true Hollywood
story is making a comeback the series
which began its original run in 1986 is
returning to e with a greater focus on
giving a voice to the major moments that
are reshaping pop culture and changing
the world so epic and I can't believe
like obviously since they're giving Busy
Philipps a show like he has been like
thirsty for like good quality content
ever since the Kardashians like they
haven't been able to do with like
failure after failure after failure and
you just like you would think that like
they would have brought this back a long
time ago cuz yeah it's a tsunami is
showing it's like our culture is even
more obsessed with like reboots Reed
no.9 with reboots with just like
celebrities and pop culture and like
each like the OJ Simpson crime show was
so successful like we're just obsessive
these moments like you would think he
would have brought it back like so much
longer ago someone there just got hired
who's in tune with what's necessary and
other people working there have not been
a lot of their new shows have been
announced I guess that's why we're
talking about it it's like it's called
the new front I think oh do they just
have their new friend happen I think
cool I know I'm up front what do they
have their up front cuz their TV new
friends digital so we should have a new
part of that we should have a new friend
okay okay original programming grow old
podcast is back patreon account Caroline
shows there's still some tickets
available almost at 100k and you know
and we have some other exciting stories
she isn't original program starting on
our show right and I was just gonna say
one more thing
oh that Natalie and Olivia from wags
were talking about this in the course
about Thrones are also getting their own
show about their family and I'm so
excited because I have been rooting for
them since you have day one and I'm so
glad that I was not the only one now we
have our dear toaster segment which is
an advice segment that you could submit
to if you emailed to your toasters at
gmail.com our lovely intern Jacob will
you be through all of your problems they
aren't honest so don't worry but we're
talking all things from relationships to
work to work like balance to wedding
whatever is whatever you guys have them
on the docket so what so is guac really
coming back girl with a podcast um I
don't know
oh okay maybe it maybe she is maybe she
is just you know just keep staying tuned
guy yeah okay first one love related my
boyfriend and I have been dating for a
little over four years and we are
currently long-distance a couple weeks
ago he brought up the topic of ring
shopping who is completely threw me
through a loop because marriage isn't
marriage supposed to be a two-person
conversation I'm 23 and not at all ready
for that important stuff in my life
why am i afraid he's not the one how do
I know for sure you don't know for sure
because you don't live near each other
and so when a long-distance relationship
is so much easier than being in a short
distance really I like don't know how to
give this kind of advice because like
I'm always giving advice for like how to
get marry and how to like not not get
marry ya know but like you don't know
enough about someone in a long-distance
relationship they're like yeah and it's
not that I think long-distance
relationships can't work like you guys
would be perfectly right for each other
put like you've never both went to a
restaurant together had food poisoning
and there's only one bathroom right you
know so like you don't know a person
until you're fighting for the toilet
you know until one of you has to go down
to the lobby bathroom wait or you don't
know a person till like you're patiently
waiting for the toilet and it's like how
will you handle yourself in that moment
how much you really care about what this
person thinks to be so true or like you
don't really truly know someone until
they need an enema right so I guess I
don't know I know been very well and
no but I know Zach because I know that
that's we'll each give ourselves our own
and I was doing hard I would see their
sit on an enema okay so morally story I
like this girl obviously he's weird
about not being sure because like how
could you be sure you don't even know
this man you've never seen them poop so
you've never even met him yeah how many
days have you spent together at once you
can't have spent more than a week
together and that's so crazy about
long-distance relationships oh yeah
honestly like I don't want to offend
they are in long-distance relationships
for so long I don't want that anyone but
they're kind of [ __ ] they know but
here's the problem with long-distance
relationships you're in them for so long
because you never really have a problem
with this person
yeah like nothing ever comes to a head
because you what you see them for most
for a week then you finally get to go
breathe you don't see a man for a month
by the time you see him again you like
them again so you never really get it's
almost ideal right but then it's not
real no no it's fake as hell its pen pal
like you might as well be writing to
someone in prison help them give him an
enema and you'll see if you love him
work-related I'm a nanny and you love
the kids I 94 by by only gripe great
word is that they're [ __ ] there's
always food on the floor and clothes all
over the goddamn place that is honestly
so overwhelming their kids what are you
afraid she's not a housekeeper she's no
yeah I clean their downstairs everyday
while watching two kids by myself but
somehow when they're both off work can't
seem to keep anything together
the kids were toasting the parents okay
the parents don't contribute okay it
almost feels as if they're not cleaning
because they know I will the next thing
I come into work and it's dirty again
I've gotten to the point where I'm
resentful in a way because I feel like I
shouldn't have to do the girly [ __ ] was
dishes when I have to do my own and also
it's just gross so how do I politely
tell these people without offending them
that I'm over the mess that is so tough
yeah stop cleaning up like you made a
huge mistake the first time he started
to clean because then you set a
precedent like you can't not clean but
you know it's not your [ __ ] job
you're not getting paid enough like stop
playing those people's house this calls
for for a little bit of passive
aggression which is a favorite tactic of
mine yeah and you know it's usually
always work so I would start with just
not cleaning the house and then if they
say why are you cleaning the house you
say I'm not a housekeeper oh and if you
want to clean the house pay me
but I know a great one here's her number
no or pay me pay me for housekeeper and
nanny I don't get paid enough for this
that's really annoying that's really in
stop stop cleaning the house yeah but
then it's like you have to live in and
dirt or the train work in a dirty like
office or train the kids like sucking
clean up after them oh my god totally
that would be a fun game yeah hype let's
do the dishes yeah first one to do all
the dishes like gets a gummy bear that's
how you would have to entice me one
gummy bear wouldn't I see oh no I don't
even like coming there's like ten M&Ms
I'll do it really as a kid yeah that's
like the golden it's like have you seen
Matilda like you're only used to two of
them yeah blue without by your pigtails
and just swing around the schoolyard
okay we're gonna do our final tear
testers before we bring out our gasps
Ashley Jacobs I'm so excited for sure
okay
friendship related okay help I need
somebody help
not just anybody help you know it needs
someone Hey that was beautiful yeah I
have five bridesmaids and one maid of
honor one of the bridesmaids has been
super passive-aggressive to me I just I
love bridesmaids really because I feel
like this has become like such a point
of contention for so many friendships
that it's like we should just do away
with the whole sister don't know I love
it
one of the thing I love like doing to
your toasters about bridesmaids Oh know
what I'm saying it's proving to me that
this is one of them has been one of them
has been super passive-aggressive to me
since I've asked her she was my big in
my sorority and one of my really close
friends I think she's bitter I didn't
ask her to be the maid of honor and now
she's making every bridal outing not as
fun because her negative energy is so
obvious I have talked to her about it
and nothing is getting better I'm
worried the day of our wedding is going
to roll around and she's going to bring
the party down in our days going to be
bitter because she's bitter
what do what you think I should do okay
there is a special place in hell for
like girls or boys who like make other
people's weddings about themselves like
it's so I don't care like how upset you
are get over it and if I was this girl I
would literally be like I don't want you
as my bridesmaids anymore because you're
obviously not the person I thought you
were then you are it's just so butthurt
about something so stupid and
superficial they're willing to ruin like
the bachelorette party the bridal shower
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] she's not even in
her grave like she's a year older than
you like
grow oh did you insure for this right I
don't know if someone on my bachelorette
party does that and is bringing negative
energy I'm gonna say pack your bags buy
a ticket and go boom no yep
pack of bags buy a ticket go to hell but
also just go home like I will not be shy
about kicking someone out of my bachelor
party because in situations like that
you just have to be selfish alright
great and I am not afraid to do so so
just note to anyone who will be invited
you could also be uninvited just like
that of course this year anything you'll
bring a positive energy only and even if
you're there and like mean you're just
having a bad week or something or like
you're feeling fat or you don't want to
drink you're on hole 30 which is never a
problem for me I never feel bad cuz I'm
beautiful and I never don't want to
drink something to one like maybe you're
not like bitter in general but you're
having a bad week I'm like I'll send you
home don't worry and maybe I'll even pay
view with likes I'm that kind of friend
what no I'm kidding maybe I'll give you
points yeah okay kidding again okay we
are going to cut you a quick break and
then we will be back with our guest from
southern charm Ashley Jacobs if you have
questions for her feel free to comment
in the Facebook and YouTube livestream
and we will do our best to get those
questions to her so we will see you in a
minute
you
and we are back with southern charms
Ashley Jacobs hello Ashley thank you so
much for having me friend joining her
fans of the show yes so that we assist
to our first question which is did you
watch the show before you went on I had
never seen season 1 or 2 it's actually a
really funny story
obviously I'm a nurse and I had a
patient one day I was going to her home
I do home care at hospice and she had
the show on and I'm doing her bandaging
and I see it's probably end of season 3
where Thomas is trying to get out the
window yeah you know yeah okay so and
I'm doing your bandage in looking at
this year I'm going my gosh this is some
good stuff you know but I wasn't aware
of what was going on so as soon as I
went home I'm like I'm gonna DVR the
rest of this even though I had no clue
I'm like there's some good drama on this
show so then you know the next season
when it came out I think there was maybe
only one only one episode head it just
premiered when I met Thomas okay
actually almost a year ago today yeah so
when I almost one year anniversary yes
well I mean yeah oh wow definitely yeah
Cinco de Mayo's when we met so when I
saw him at a bar I didn't know if that
was him and I wasn't so familiar and the
funniest thing was my girlfriend's a big
fan of the show and I had just watched
an episode with her cuz she DVR did we
watch it on a Wednesday and she was
going away for a bachelorette party on
Friday and when I went to this bar I saw
him and I go him do you think as I had
and I was like Nikki would die if she
was here of course she takes the worst
weekend so when I saw him in a distance
first of all where I was wearing a
sombrero and you know all the guys were
in board shorts and flip-flops and you
know I'm wearing bathing suit with a
cover-up and here's this guy Crossway
dressed to the nines he just stuck out
like a sore thumb
white jeans yes white probably
the funniest thing about it was I'd only
seen the first episode and the way they
made the first episode look like was
that he were gonna get with Landon okay
so I figured he's in a relationship
right so I was looking for her and I
didn't see him and he was waiting behind
the bar for a drink and I was with a
table of friends and I said I'm like
that guy you know needs to come join us
he's by himself so his when he did on TV
goes just wasn't really like that it was
more like come over here I really want a
picture with you to send to my
girlfriend I want a selfie that was this
but I thought he'd be flattered by that
I wasn't I didn't have this intention of
oh I'm gonna get him and trap him I
wanted a picture when she never gave to
me till the end of the night so he was
really funny because he told me because
I because I asked him I said you know
why didn't you give me that picture
earlier and he goes because usually
people come up to take selfies they get
their selfies and he leaves yeah he goes
I didn't want you to go so yeah I wanted
you to stay so that was be it that
thought oh sweet
what about how they want to know if
since become being on the show you're
still a full time nurse yes yes I just
started I just finally got my license in
South Carolina so actually it's still
temporary or trying to get it get the
actual license so that's the only thing
because I see all these people looking
cuz it's public record so people are in
look like oh she's not a nurse ocean
yeah I need to say I have a temporary
license California is where I'm from so
it's big state and they always say
they're really tardy to get that license
going so I'm still waiting on that but I
am working on a temporary license yes
I'm working yeah full-time and I have
three patients go to their home so when
did you move to Charleston
so I gosh I think it was beginning of
August oh wow so that's that's what
people you know don't know is I was in a
transition I was in a transitionary
period I was I grew up in California I
was ready for a change like la San Diego
do I want to go to New York well I have
friends and family in Vegas small places
and I actually had some connections and
I was applying out there and I got two
job
out there and I had to sign a contract
as a three year contract and this was
around the same time that I had started
dating Thomas and I said to Thomas I
said you know I wonder if we could still
make this work but I I'm going to be out
here once I sign this contract and he
goes well you can work as a nurse
anywhere why not try Charleston if
you're really wanting to get out try it
just see and I thought you know what I
would I would love to try it
and it doesn't work at least I know then
sign up and work move somewhere else and
always wonder what if yes yeah so that
was how I came out here so I was ready
for a change and I thought I just want
to I just want to do something different
I want to get out of my comfort zone and
you know people say what you moved all
the way for love well I move for the
adventure for doing something new why
not take that risk what's the worst that
can happen
yeah well you're only doing something
new with the show now yeah how has that
been yeah and the problems are crazy and
about you've experienced both the good
and the bad
how do you just kind of go from just
like being a nurse to like people like
well who don't know you having that
things to say about right well the thing
is is when I moved out there Charles
South Carolina has really you know
strict laws you have to show proof of
residency that you're living in an
apartment you have to get your driver's
license you have to do so much stuff so
it was a process of getting that so in
the meantime I wasn't working when the
filming had started really a lot of the
people on the show didn't know filming
was if it was even going on they didn't
sign a contract really until a few days
prior yeah so when I was with Thomas and
we were talking about it you know I kind
of went back and forth and I thought why
not again I'll be as plus one right you
know that's that's what I went into I
thought I'm an adrenaline junkie you
know I love I'm like this is a story you
know it'll be what all of the when I
watch the show which I haven't seen
everything when I watch the show I
thought this looks like fun they go out
to parties only so I went into it you
know differently but it wasn't expected
and you know Bravo's not paying me what
people don't realize you know they're
getting me interesting they're getting
me for free and that's what was
surprising the price was right yeah so
you know that's what's hard is I went in
as his plus-one and you see how much I
talk and I think that you know I'm very
transparent open and when they started
asking me to do more scenes Thomas goes
oh my gosh they want more of you than
they want of me and I'd have to say I
was sort of flattered you know like ego
stroke you know like they like me they
think I'm cool so you know yes I like
I'm like you know my head was a city
unlike sure you know yeah I didn't
realize you know when you sign that
release they're able to fictionalize
your story any way that they want yeah
so yes so that's that's how that started
are you well joining the filming like
would you want to do another season if
given the opportunity if you were
getting paid if I was getting paid we'll
see yes yes so this week on the show or
last week you sat down with Katherine
and it was very pleasant conversation
what were you thinking like going into
it and what's our relationship like now
with Katherine like in this moment I
mean she reached out to me the night
before okay on a Wednesday night she
texted Thomas and or choosing a text of
Thomas and she said you know can I get
Ashley's phone number and I was like yes
because my first interaction with her at
Shep's party was I would like to get to
know her better - it wasn't the
friendliest we didn't have a lot of
interaction and I thought yeah this is a
good chance to get to know her so I
replied to her immediately Nate said
yeah when do you want to do it tomorrow
I'm thinking well I gotta spray I'm
thinking all these things no no they had
to get a job I got it yeah I'm thinking
in hindsight I wish it was also a 90
degree weather the heat she I don't know
how she handles she was wearing this
robe you know and I'm see what it was
looked great she was but I was barely
covered and she was covered up and not
dripping as just born lucky yeah and I
think they're used to that whether I'm
California so I'm just cool like this
I'm like my friend Gemma I'm like what
it was horrible for me but I went into
it I was I got there early
I was sort of you know try not to psych
myself out but it's already intimidating
meeting somebody you know that has
children with meeting someone that has
children you know with boyfriend cuz
Tommy isn't the first guy I've ever
dated with children oh okay so then you
add cameras right okay so and they're in
like the bushes and they're behind you
and I'm sweating and everything my heart
rates going yeah and you know she's not
always she's not as talkative as I am
mm-hmm so it seemed like I was talking a
lot more but someone had to do the
talking
and you know when I would ask you know
questions like wanting to get to know
her she didn't want to talk about that
she wanted to get to know who's around
her children so it did seem like I did a
lot of talking but I was very nervous
yes I was meeting her for the first time
but is also nervous you know with
cameras because again that's all a new
experience and I wish it would have you
know happened off camera but first just
to kind of break the ice
yeah well you did an Instagram live last
week that I watched talking about
Patricia who I take umbrage or hates her
I like I just I just think she's just a
mean lady just mean and you were talking
about someone named late what Patricia
is friends ain't even one of mention
okay you were defending Katherine which
I thought was really sweet so are you
guys in a good place today we're getting
there well that's actually being
presumptuous you know I hope we can get
there I mean you'll have to stay tuned
to see what happens and you know words
that were exchanged and obviously you
saw the beginning of the episode where
the egg donor so yes yeah I got a lot of
heat for that obviously so you'll you'll
have to stay tuned to see what really
happens but I I did bump into her
recently and I tried to ask her to lunch
and she wasn't it's too soon yeah I
think so I I would love to you know get
to that point where we can sit down for
coffee
you know but it's when you you have to
put the children first yeah and they're
the priority and it's not about her
needs about Thomas and me or Thomas and
her it's about the children and if we
can somehow all work together that would
be great because I don't want you know
to be excluded I wanted her to be
excluded and things that we do I would
like for us all to you know be yes well
sort of kind of you know I come from a
divorced family and my stepdad was you
know very involved and I always slept
with a picture with my mom and dad on
there their wedding day next to my bed
him I slept I'd never had any problems
with that he was always very respectful
so I understand and I'm not trying to
cross any you know boundaries and I'm
not trying to be them I'm just trying to
bring lots of love and light and just be
a good role model yeah I used to babysit
nanny and I was counseled Urso yes see
you not today what is that um when
you're a counselor training CIT yes we
had to do that and then I did do camp
and it's counselor I always works with
children so I love children so much so
you know when I started dating Thomas
I just I was actually attracted to him
more because he had children right
for some reason because their priorities
are different and it's just yeah it's
being part of a family not it's it's not
saying that I am in their family I'm
just saying there's something wonderful
you know I work with as a nurse and I
love working with patients in their home
because I'm a part of their family
yeah and I love that you know so that's
what really attracted me all right who's
gonna be on the reunion and if so do you
know like in what capacity I don't know
no not yet no I mean I'm not a main cast
member or even a part-time cast member I
know that Naomi last season did it so I
mean that's why I really appreciate you
guys taking the time to hear me out and
have this platform because unlike
everyone else that gets to do the
confessionals right you don't remember -
but I know mama says Instagram that you
do eventually do confessionals know I'll
go in front of a green screen though
that was for bravotv.com
okay that's separate than
can be frustrating stephane than Hamaker
which contracts to Bravo got it so
they're they're not affiliated yes
so that's stuff that's different and I
was really grateful to you yeah do that
but you know when I watched these scenes
and then I see Catherine say something
or something I'm going I wish I can
spend my truth yes and say how I was
feeling like he just asked me were you
nervous I would I would have loved that
yeah that's very frustrating i bravo
does that a lot with like subsidiary
characters like yeah I love Thomas like
she's on every season of real houses of
Atlanta but she never really gets to
yeah better stuff because she's not a
real character especially since they
have me in every episode right it's one
thing if I was just his plus-one and I'm
in the background but the fact that you
know right so and Whitney did try he
like sent attacks and they did consider
it and they said they don't consider it
very often so they actually you know
took it up and so that was a big deal
but no I know not enough not yes that's
why I really appreciate this this is the
first we got for you you've talked about
any owe me and I feel like this season
on the show I'm so glad to see like a
group of girls and they have a really
good friendship do you have that sort of
friendship with any of the cast members
and who are you closest with the sizing
off camera and friends with Elizabeth I
love Elizabeth JD was great I really
like Craig I like Craig Craig T I really
love him so and he said some nice things
about me and he's you know very
reasonable you know it comes from the
heart and yeah and Shep we bumped into
him and he's always like hey your string
said I think the sad thing is that the
one woman I was able to confide in was
Patricia and you see that there's been
some tension recently and I don't want
to get into that but anyway - I like
Whitney yeah like Whitney who do you
think they'd be the hardest time like in
the group when you first kind of showed
up well they were all really kind to me
you know until you go back and watch
where they're going she's dehydrated
she's thinking you know they were all
very warm what do you have to say to
people who say
Thursday oh my god right there I am
parched and I'm yes yes I'm drinking my
water right here so thank you daddy
hydrated okay so we're gonna the nurse
is a nurse right I would give some
normal saline sodium chloride vein so
that's that's more but now I'm not just
thirsty Julia I'm hungry yeah
so it's gosh we have your back and forth
yeah when people kind of keep up with
you follow along on social media with
you and Thomas where can they find you
yeah on Instagram I mean this is a sort
of a new world you know to me I mean I
always had my clothes following and now
you're getting all these people well all
the time yes you know I try to post some
real stuff and little pictures of us but
I've just I've had so many people that
contact me with what do you want to wear
this dress do you wanna wear this
jewelry do you want to it don't you yes
and what girl would say no and if I can
make a little profit off of it why the
hell not yes
no I thought you know I'm getting so
much oh she's just in it for the fame
she's just in it for this well no I am
working my ass off yeah but there's a
nurse and if people could really see I
wish I can show that on Instagram right
I wish I can show people what my real
life is like helping these patients
change putting my wheelchair changing
bedpans bathing down you know wiping
down you mean man I wish they can see
that but you can't do that you know
because of privacy confidentiality but
that isn't I realize and they don't see
that they see the more glamorous and fun
side but you know I do like to be a girl
I wear scrubs when I get dirty and you
should see the way I look we're not
recognizing you would not recognize me
but when I have an opportunity to you
know dress up and yeah I'm gonna take it
so well you can vote Ashley Ashley H
Jacobs on it sir yes obviously Thomas
Ravenel as well we're so glad you could
be here thank you so much for coming you
guys we are back tomorrow again we're
here all week actually okay I thought
tomorrow was Tuesday what's tomorrow's
Thursday what a great feeling a work
week three day with egg a Monday Monday
to Friday face podcast
so make sure to subscribe to us on
YouTube like our Facebook page and then
also leave us a 5-star review in the
podcast happen if you want to comment on
how beautiful we are like that would be
a cocktail
also our first episode of our patreon is
gonna come out later today so stay tuned
and sign up if you haven't yet patriot
comm fashion morning toast let's see
that tomorrow thang
you